-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
and comedian you know from
shows such as
"Broad City"
and "The Good Place."
She currently stars in
the third season of
the hit HBO series "Barry."
The season finale airs on
HBO and HBO Max this Sunday.
Let's take a look.
-[ Whispering ] Sally.
Hey. Sally, wake up.
It's the whole home screen.
[ Gasps, laughs ]
Look at your freakin' face.
It's huge.
That face is being
seen everywhere this morning.
And you're still a 98%
on Rotty T's.
-This is insane.
-It's all happening!
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend D'Arcy Carden,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, D'Arcy.
I'm so happy to have you here.
-[ Laughs ]
-I know.
And, D'Arcy,
it should be noted, you said,
you know, if Jeff Goldblum
wants to stick around,
you would be happy with it.
-I'm not in charge here,
but if he wants to stay, he can.
-Well, I think we're all
very happy about that.
Let me just say, I have enjoyed
this season very -- so much.
-Barry much?
-Barry much.
[ Laughter ]
But this was a season,
like a lot of great television,
that was interrupted by COVID.
So, how far into
this season were you
when the rug got pulled out?
-When the thing happened?
-Yeah.
-We were doing table reads, so
we were about to start filming.
We were on the --
You know, L.A. lockdown
started on a Friday.
We went -- We did our table read
on a Wednesday,
when it was still like,
"What's going on?"
-Yeah.
-And we went to our
little table read,
and everyone had like
one individual hand sanitizer,
like that would fix it.
-Yeah.
And everybody was like,
"Should we hug?
Should we not?"
And then a couple of actors and
I got into Henry Winkler's car
and drove to lunch and,
like, shared food, appetizers.
So we didn't know anything
at that point.
We knew absolutely nothing.
And then we got the call
that the world did the thing.
-Even after lockdown,
if Henry Winkler asked me
to get in his car, I would.
For what it's worth.
-You have to.
Yeah, you have to.
-I wouldn't say no to
Henry Winkler.
-You know, like every morning,
I called Jeff and said,
"What are we going to
wear today?"
-It is...
And let me just stress,
you might be
the first two people
who have ever been on this show
that went
black, yellow, and green.
-That's not a normal combo?
-And here you are together.
-I said, "I'll wear my pj's."
You wear a cool cardigan.
And our son will just wear
a nice blue shirt."
-Mom, dad, why do you guys
have to dress alike?!
-We laid out your clothes.
You refused to wear your
black, yellow, and green.
-I know. I'm so sorry.
This is -- I want to say
how really deeply excited I am.
A trailer just
was out this week.
You are in
a television adaptation of
"A League of Their Own."
-I am.
-A perfect film that
I rewatched recently,
and I'm wondering --
Obviously,
I'm a little bit older than you.
Did that movie
mean something to you?
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It totally did.
You know,
I played baseball as a kid
and I played a bunch of sports,
and that one --
There was, like, so many good
'90s baseball movies,
but this one
really, really was --
meant something special to me.
Uh-oh. Oh, yeah.
-Well, you have a photo.
You mentioned you played
baseball, so I want to, um...
So, this is --
Is this a photo of you
that was then made into
a button?
-You got that right.
-Yeah, okay.
-Really just, like,
I want to just point out
I did that myself.
-Yeah.
It's really nice.
-I was a little kid.
I wasn't, like, a hairstylist,
but I was able to create that.
Like, that's...
-Yeah.
And, now, are you still --
-That's not nothing.
You're still doing work with
BDT & Associates, right?
-Yes, yes.
-This is wonderful.
Also, I feel like
a lot of people did --
in this era, did a lot of sports
with turtlenecks, right?
-Yeah. Or, like,
a nice mock turtleneck.
-Just a mock turtleneck, yeah.
-Can I just tell you that --
-Oh, yeah.
I'm sorry, Jeff.
I didn't mean to
shout out your...
[ Laughter ]
-Another '90s movie that meant
the absolute world to me
was "Jurassic Park."
Is "Jurassic Park."
-Yeah.
-I'm a huge --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is nice, right?
-As we all are.
-Yeah.
-Nice segue?
-Yeah, very nice.
-Thanks.
-You could do this.
-Okay, great. Let's switch.
Very natural segue.
-I have to tell you,
my parents took my --
I almost just said "children" --
my siblings and I out of school
to see opening day of
"Jurassic Park."
And I was about that age,
maybe --
Yeah, about that age,
a little bit --
-So older than this.
Somewhere between
these two ages?
Yeah, okay. Gotcha.
-I really like that part.
So cute.
And then let's just look
at the nose.
-Oh, yeah. That's great.
That's a beautiful photo.
-Noses change, though.
-They do, yeah.
Can we get a close-up?
-Noses change.
Noses change.
They don't tell you that.
-They don't tell you that.
So, you got taken out of school.
-Yes.
And we were watching the movie,
and there was a moment
during the movie when you guys
see the first dinosaur,
where, again, I was too old
to have this thought,
but I was I was like,
"Oh, dinosaurs do exist?
Oh, they always say they don't,
but I guess they do.
Somewhere, they do."
-The funny thing about that is,
that's exactly what
teachers say why not to
take your kids out of school.
Like, you not only did you
miss school,
you came back with,
like, bad info.
-Totally.
-Yeah.
-I didn't learn about
any planets that day.
-But I did not know this
about your parents.
They were super-cool
Bay-area music --
More than fans.
They had a music magazine.
-They did, yeah.
My parents had a music magazine
called "BAM."
-BAM.
-What the hell?
-I have every back copy of it.
-Jeff, are you kidding?
-Yes.
-Okay, you are.
But you -- Did you --
Do you remember BAM?
No, it's okay if you don't.
Let's not do this.
-No, I kind of do.
Yes, yes, yes.
-It was like in
the '70s, '80s, and '90s.
-Oh, wow!
-Yeah.
-So it had a run.
-Yeah, it had a really good run.
And, yeah, it was
really a cool way to grow up,
because we got to go to concerts
and we would get
boxes of tapes and CDs
and we would --
-And did your parents have
an expectation that, as a child,
you were supposed to be
cooler than your peers
as far as your music knowledge?
-They were kind of --
Yeah, absolutely.
-Okay.
-Yeah. My mom especially.
It was my dad's magazine,
but my mom was like...
She was -- She'd be driving
in her little minivan,
and whoever was playing,
she would be like,
"Who's playing drums on this?
Who produced this?
Who's doing backup vocals
on this?"
And we would scramble.
Whoever could answer first was,
like, mom's favorite that day.
-Wow!
And this is, like, '70s and
'80s, like, rock 'n' roll music?
-Yes. Totally. Yeah, yeah.
Whatever -- It was old stuff,
but it was like, you know,
whatever was new
in California at the time
we were listening to.
-And you did as a --
You got to meet Huey Lewis.
-Yeah. A few times.
Sorry to brag.
-That's a huge deal.
I would be very excited by that.
-I've never met Huey Lewis.
-Have you met Huey Lewis?
-I've never met --
-Okay, so you're telling me
I'm the only --
Have you guys met Huey Lewis?
You have. Okay, cool.
-Alright, great.
-Yeah.
That guy frickin' rocks. Yeah.
-But how did --
Tell us the story of how --
Because -- I feel like you also
met him in a unique way.
It's, one, exciting to meet him,
but, two, the way you met him.
-I think I was about
5 years old,
again, a little younger than --
maybe about the age of tummy.
-Okay.
-Tummy and nose, yeah.
We're thinking this age.
-Okay, gotcha.
-My parents took
my older sister, Laney, and I
to see Huey Lewis and the News.
And my dad was buds with him,
so after the concert --
It was my first concert.
And after the concert, we went
backstage, and everybody, like,
sort of couldn't find Huey.
And, apparently, he had had
what he thought was
a bad concert, a bad show.
-Impossible.
-Impossible. Thank you.
And then my parents sort of,
like, lost sight of me,
little 5-year-old D'Arcy.
And I come around the corner,
like, holding Huey's hand.
And, guys, he had
a huge smile on his face.
I think I cheered him up.
-Yeah, a little -- I think if
a 5-year-old comes --
I will say, that is kind of
what I think about, like,
parents who have
a music magazine.
They're like,
"Oh, where's our kid?"
-Yeah, yeah, totally.
I'm like, "Also,
keep an eye on your kid.
Keep an eye -- Maybe don't take
your kids out of school and
keep an eye on your kid when
you're backstage at a concert."
-That was also a
middle-of-the-day Huey Lewis
concert that they'd taken
you out of school for.
-Yeah, yeah. They took me out --
Yeah, it was the SATs.
-The teachers were like,
"You know, they do, like --
They show movies at night,
as well.
You could, like..."
-"You have a whole weekend."
-"You could do both.
You could do school and go see
'Jurassic Park.'
-I think we needed to see
the first showing.
That was the whole thing.
-And, so, at what time in your
life -- And, again --
Well, I actually want to go back
to "A League of Their Own"
to finish it.
You obviously had to play
a lot of baseball.
-Yeah.
-Did the skills come back?
-Oh, honey, they never left.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I don't mean to be like that.
I don't mean to be like that.
-That's great!
-Do you play baseball?
-Do I ever, yes.
-You know what? You know what?
-Are you showing us
how you play baseball?
-I'm just starting to play.
I like to pitch.
-You know what?
You know what's funny?
We got three
Pittsburgh guys up here.
-We do. This is all Pittsburgh,
'cause you shot "League of Their
Own" in Pittsburgh.
-We shot "League of Their Own"
in Pittsburgh.
-And you fell in love with it.
You fell in love with the city.
-I totally did.
-All you got to do is go there.
-Yeah, that's true.
And that's --
For the audience at home,
all you gotta do is go there.
You'll fall in love with it.
Were you born there?
-No, my dad was, yeah.
-Okay, daddy was born there,
but then you lived there
when you were a baby.
When you were
just about that age.
-Yeah, when I was -- Yeah.
-When Seth was --
-When I was -- My ballet photo
not available, yeah.
-And you grew up there.
-I grew up there, yes.
I saw Roberto Clemente play
at Forbes Field.
-Look at that.
-Oh, my God.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Pretty hard to beat that.
It's gonna be hard to
top that fact.
What a delight to
have both of you out here.
Thank you so much
for being back, D'Arcy.
Thank you for
sticking around, Jeff.
You guys, that's D'Arcy Carden
right there.
The season finale of "Barry,"
in which she is fantastic,
airs this Sunday, June 12th,
and "A League of Their Own"
will be out this summer
on Prime Video.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."